British explorer Bear Grylls is best
known to TV audiences for discoveries
man vs. wild known as born survivor Bear
Grylls in the UK the magic of TV makes
Grylls look like the ultimate survivor
but the truth isn't quite so clear cut
from his genuine scrapes with death too
embarrassing leaks about his so-called
survival shows this is the untold truth
of Bear Grylls school bullies anyone
who's seen his shows might be surprised
to learn that Grylls was bullied in
school the guy seems pretty tough now
but he wasn't always like that in
response to the bullying he received at
school young Grylls decided to take up
karate along with a few of his friends
three years later he got his black belt
and went to train in Japan as the
youngest member of the karate Union of
Great Britain Grylls described the
experience in his book mud sweat and
tears each night we slept on the floor
in small wooden Japanese huts and by day
we learned how to fight real and hard
the trading was more exacting and
demanding than anything I had previously
encountered military man after leaving
school grille spent several months
hiking the Indian Himalayas he told the
Hindustan Times I spent quite some time
in India before I joined the army I went
out there climbing and up in West Bengal
and all around Darjeeling we were in
Calcutta for a while and then we were
with the Indian Army as well Grylls even
flirted with the idea of joining the
Indian army himself at the time but
ultimately decided to enroll in the
military at home in Great Britain Grylls
joined the United Kingdom Special Forces
Reserve in 1994 and served with 21
regiment Special Air Service or SAS for
three years receiving training and
everything from desert and winter
warfare to evasive driving climbing and
explosives freefall Grylls might have
only been in SAS Reserve but that
doesn't mean he got to skip out on any
of the dangerous stuff Grylls second
deployment to Africa ended in a terrible
accident that almost claimed his life he
told the Guardian in Africa my parachute
ripped at 17,000 feet I blacked out and
on landing broke my back I spent the
next 18 months in braces and plaster I
was lucky to survive let alone walk
again
a friend of Grylls who was with him at
the time told the Guardian I look back
and think of him in that body brace
after that horrific parachute fall and
it's incredible that he survived it then
to look at what he's achieved since then
I'd never have thought it possible
top of the world breaking three
vertebrae after a 17,000 foot fall would
be enough to put most people off heights
from
but grills didn't let it stop him grills
lived his childhood dream to climb
Everest when he scaled Earth's highest
mountain in 1998 less than two years
after his near-fatal Africa fall Everest
is obviously no walk in the park and
grills almost met his in for a second
time when some loose ice left him
hanging on for dear life we were in the
first stage of the Everest descent when
the ground gave way leaving me swinging
on the end of this rope clutching at
these black and glassy walls
dinner-party in 2005 Grylls and fellow
explored Lieutenant Commander Alan veal
stage one of the weirdest stunts of
Grylls career they broke the record for
the world's highest dinner party when
they flew a hot-air balloon to a height
of 24,000 262 feet and climbed down to a
dinner table suspended below the balloon
braving temperatures of minus 50 degrees
Celsius after enjoying a three-course
meal together
the daredevil duo dedicated the venture
to her royal Majesty Queen Elizabeth and
sky dived back down to ground with full
bellies controversies Grylls was the
subject of controversy in 2008 when US
survival consultant mark Y nerd started
talking to the British media about his
time working on Grylls show man vs. wild
claiming that the star was a fraud
Weinert revealed that during one episode
he personally assembled a Polynesian
style bamboo raft off-camera only for
Grylls to add the finishing touches and
take the credit and after shooting on
the episode concluded Weinert claims the
ex-military man left for a motel and
that wasn't the only time the show
allegedly faked Grylls whereabouts
according to the whistleblower Grylls
apparently spent a few nights in a
luxurious Lodge during the filming of
the Sierra Nevada mountains episode
Grylls responded to the claims by saying
if people felt misled on how the first
series was represented I'm really sorry
for that we filmed these things over six
days and after filming the night stuff
we're back with a crew and a Basecamp
Lodge adventure dad when your dad eats
bugs and gets peed on for a living
you're bound to have an interesting
childhood that's definitely true for
Bear Grylls kids when they aren't
staying on the houseboat they have
moored on the banks of London's River
Thames Grylls and his family live on a
remote island off the coast of Wales in
2013 Grylls found himself in hot water
with the local council after erecting a
huge metal slide that ended with a drop
off a cliff face into the sea below
Grylls defended his decision by saying
the slide is not for the Payne public
and therefore the health and safety is
not for other people it's from
and the kids and friends to use when
we're there it has an element of danger
to it you do hit the water pretty hard
but do you know what there are a lot
more dangerous things around he came
under criticism again in 2015 when he
purposely stranded his eleven-year-old
son on a rocky outcrop off the island to
serve as a training aide for the Royal
National Lifeboat institution survivor
games Bear Grylls is hugely popular in
the US and his native UK but he also has
a massive following in an unlikely place
China Grylls 2012 best seller mud sweat
and tears was voted the most influential
book in China the year it was released
and in 2016 Grylls invited several
Chinese celebrities to join him in the
wild including former NBA star Yao Ming
Olympic swimmer foo wonhui and Robin Lee
one of China's richest tech moguls the
show aired under the name survivor games
and featured a print is similar to
mission survive a UK series in which
Grylls takes eight celebrities on a
two-week hike through unforgiving
terrain and eliminates them one by one
despite the country's love for Grylls
however the Chinese version didn't go
over well viewers complained that the
show was tasteless and disgusting after
Grylls forced the contestants to drink
their own urine disgusting
oh yeah but tasteless will have to trust
Grylls on that okay there's no getting
away from it that really is pretty
horrible it's like wool and it's salty
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]